عام من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه توسطت
فيه كافه الاطراف الدوليه لوقف الحرب الا
انها لم تنجح لتعرض الصين في ذكرى الاولى
للحرب خططا باثني عشر بندا لاحلال السلام
بين الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي
الكريم وصف المبادره الصينيه بانها تستحق
الاهتمام منتقدا لظروف الراهنه التي تحول
دون تنفيذها
اننا ننظر في خطه اصدقاءنا الصينيين
باهتمام كبير انها عمليه طويله في الوقت
الراهن لا نرى الظروف التي من شانها ان
تضع هذه القضيه على مسار سلمي العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره
[موسيقى]
رحبت بحذر بالخطه مع التحفظ على بعض
البنود
اكد ان فكره توسط الحالي في روسيا في
السلام امر مبشر
من الصواب الاعتقاد بانه اذا كانت هناك
افكار تتوافق بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام
القانون الدولي وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع
الصين في هذه النقطه
كما انه عبر عن رغبته بلقاء نظيره الصيني
لمناقشه العمليات العسكريه والعلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
بكين من جانبها لم تعلن عن نيه مشابهه بل
اكدت انها ستكون على تواصل مع جميع
الاطراف لمناقشه خطط السلام المقترحه
مشيره انها علمت برغبه للقاء الرئيس
الصيني لكنها لم تعلم كيف سيتم اللقاء
تتخذ الصين موقفا واضحا للغايه وثابتا من
الازمه الاوكرانيه نحن على اتصال مع جميع
الاطراف المعنيه بما في ذلك اوكرانيا
ردود فعل غربيه متفاوته قابلت المبادره
الصينيه بعضها كان مشجعا والاخر كان مشككا
اما في الولايات المتحده فقد شككت
المخابرات والبينتاجون بدور الصين بينما
ترك البيت الابيض الباب مفتوحا حول مساهمه
بكين بالحل لكن الابرز هي تسريبات صحفيه
عن توجه غربي للضغط على كييف للقبول
بالمفاوضات خلال اشهر وعمر العربيه